move now my house is just there
the human spirit women's rights the
environment
just some of the important issues
explored in the films on show
at the eighth agile film festival in
qatar its award-winning world cinema
meets home-grown talent yes film are an
amazing way to entertain
but it's an amazing easy way to get to
hearts and minds of people
and this is what we're trying now for
the last 10 years to show
that there's so much you can do with
film it has so much power
to change everything for the better and
we need to use it
but given the events of the past few
months this year's festival
is a little different fewer people are
attending the festival this year due to
the coronavirus and social distancing
regulations now the foreign directors
actors and actresses
that would have walked this red carpet
will be now attending online a lot of
the films are also going to be screened
online but despite these challenges as
the festival slogan goes
the show goes on people always tell us
that young
people are going to save the world and
it's young people who will be judging
these films
the jury is made up of 8 to 25 year olds
they will be watching online in groups
and then discussing what they've seen
how do you do it there is fun and
fantasy
but most of it is tackling serious and
difficult subjects from war
to child labour and the agile festival
also showcases homegrown talent
16 films shorts and animations by qatari
filmmakers
all with a message this one is called
hope
it's about a sea turtle with a slight
disability but he perseveres in his
journey to get out to the sea
having to avoid predators and pollution
along the way
perhaps a message in how to face
challenges in life
and how to take care of life around us
i'm going to show how the activities
is going to affect them and affect their
journey from
the day they are born to the final
destination
uh it's all based on reality reality all
the obstacles are actual obstacles they
face
we want to turtle sanctuaries we saw how
they live what they are facing the
issues they are having and we all convey
it through the film
audiences can watch most of these movies
online some are screened in cinemas
and for those who live in doha they can
buy a ticket for an outdoor drive-in
at a time when many people around the
world face social restrictions
a mix of foreign films thought provoking
issues
reality fantasy and maybe just a little
bit of hope
is a welcome escape even if it's just
for an hour
or two stephanie decker al-jazeera doha